-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging with our pal
Adam Sandler, who stars --
-That was nice of you.
Get them riled up again.
-No, come on. "Hustle."
Let's talk about this.
Let's talk about "hustle."
-Right.
-Congrats.
It's getting great reviews.
I love it because
it's almost like --
To me, it's almost like "Rocky"
for basketball.
-Yes.
It's Philly.
We shot it in Philly.
My heart's out to Philly
with the tragedy yesterday.
It's terrible with the shooting.
And love to everyone in Philly.
But, yes, we had a great time
in Philadelphia.
You guys know.
-The Roots know, exactly.
The Roots are in --
They're in the soundtrack.
-We got a great tune
of The Roots in there,
got a lot of good Philly music
in there.
And they were so nice to us
while we were shooting
and they just treated us
like family, everybody there.
So, thank you to Philly.
And then we also shot in Spain.
We went to Spain because
I discover this kid in Spain
and bring him back to,
you know, Philly
to try to get him into the NBA.
But I was telling Jimmy,
when I went there,
I was swimming in
the Mediterranean, right?
It's very salty,
the sea over there.
The Mediterranean's
got a lot of salt.
So you float.
You float.
You don't even have to try
to tread water, you just float.
So I'm floating around,
having a fun time floating.
Sandman just floating around.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I look up and I see a beach.
And I start floating
closer to the beach.
Everybody's nude.
They're all feeling great
about themselves being nude.
And no one even cares.
There's older people nude.
Young -- Good --
People who look good,
people who don't
look so good nude.
Everyone's nude.
They don't care.
They just feel comfortable.
They're just like,
"It doesn't matter.
This is me.
This is who I am.
I'm going to be nude."
So I go, "You know what?
Let me do that.
Let me try that.
I want to feel comfortable
and confident.
And everyone
seems to be cool here.
Let me do this."
So I'm swimming.
I stand up in the water.
I take my bathing suit off.
I'm still underwater.
I'm kind of slowly working up
the confidence.
I take my bathing suit off.
And I'm, like, standing there.
I go, "I shouldn't do this."
I'm like, "Someone's
going to take my picture
and ruin my life.
Let me just stay underwater.
This was a mistake."
And I'm looking
for my bathing suit.
But because it's so salty,
the testicles and the --
They were, like, floating up,
so you can see them kind of
floating on top of the water
and the other thing -- the thing
attached to the testicle,
on top of the testicles,
was floating around, too,
and I was flying
to push it down.
It kept coming back up
and floating.
And then --
So there was
a Spanish seagull nearby.
[ Rim shot ]
And the Spanish seagull,
I think,
it translated to the word,
"worm."
And it starts coming towards me.
And then one of the other
seagulls, "No, no, no worm.
No worm."
-No, no.
-But then a third seagull goes,
"McDonald's French fry."
So they started coming at me.
I gave it to them.
I was a guest in their country.
I said, "You have a good time."
-That's what a gentleman does.
You're a good man.
You're a gentleman.
-That's how they raised me.
-I love this movie.
It's so good.
It's funny.
And, you know, I have a friend.
His name's Milton Lee.
He works for the Nets.
-Right, right.
-And he's got eyes
that none of us have.
He discovers talent.
He knows --
And it's a long road.
-Oh, yeah, man.
-You're so lucky if you
get to play in the NBA.
-Oh, my God, the hard work
everybody puts in
to get in the league.
To be seen by the league
to get to the next step
to get in the league,
to stay in the league,
it's so much hard work.
These guys work --
It's ridiculous.
It's working out constantly
and just --
And so many people
want to be there.
So you're just fighting
for your spot.
-Yeah.
-Anyways...
-And you eat a lot of really
great fast food in this.
-Yes, I eat a lot
of cheesesteaks.
-You eat cheesesteaks.
I saw Pat's in there.
But I also saw KFC in there,
one jam.
-Yes, yes.
-I got real hungry
watching the movie.
-My character enjoys food.
-He really does, yeah, yeah.
But it's great.
It's heartwarming.
It's funny, and if you love
basketball or sports,
you've got to check this out.
Here's a clip --
Adam Sandler in "Hustle."
Take a look at this.
-Thank you, buddy.
-Finish it.
Come on, man.
Alright, your first year
in the league,
you're going to get no calls.
You need a handout?
Get out here.
Don't look so sad.
Go ahead, zoom in on that
sad face of his right now.
And I want you
to finish through it.
Let's go. Alright.
Show him the side.
That's right. Go.
Okay, yeah.
Alright, you absorb the contact.
I need you to finish
through the contact, alright?
Alex, you get that?
Okay, we're getting there.
Go, go, go, go, go.
And cut, cut. Move.
Push it.
Go down all the way.
Now finish it.
Oh! That's how you
take it to the rim.
What happened?
Were you on me?
Always on the money, sweetheart.
Good God.
-He is mad because he's hungry.
-[ Laughs ]
-What'd he say?
'Cause I'm what?
He made a fat joke?
[ Chuckles ]
Yeah.
-That's right.
Adam Sandler, everybody!
"Hustle" is in theaters now
and on Netflix this Wednesday.